يتواصل هذا الجسر في يومها الثالث حيث يتم
ارسال طائرات يوم الامس كان هنالك طائره
محمله بعشره اطنان من المساعدات المختلفه
بالاضافه الى طائرتين اليوم في مطار
الدولي وتحديدا في منطقه الشحن يتم ارسال
عبرها عشره اطنان اليوم تم ارسال عشرين طن
في هذه الطائره في خلفيه هنالك عشره اطنان
تم وضعها
ليتم ارسالها مباشره والمساعدات هي
مساعدات غذائيه وايوائيه والطبيه بالدرجه
الاولى يتم ارسالها عبر رفيق مختص يشرف
على عمليه ارسال هذه المساعدات من مطار
الملك خالد الدوليه عبر طائره السي 1
تيرتي التابع للقوات المسلحه السعوديه
التي تقوم بارسال هذه المساعدات مباشره
الى مطار بورت سودان حيث هنالك في
استقبالها فريق مختص من مركز الملك سلمان
الذي ذهب في اليوم الاول للجسر الجوي
الاغاتي السعودي في مطار بورت سودان
وعملها على تنظيم وتسهيل دخول هذه
المساعدات مباشره الى داخل مطار بورتسودان
ومن ثم التعاون مع المنظمات السودانيه
المحليه الاغاثيه الانسانيه العامله هناك
لتسهيل توزيعها بشكل مباشر وتوزيعها على
المحتاجين والمستفيدين منها بالدرجه
الاولى في الحقيقه نايف هنالك العديد من
منصات او العديد من المواقع التي تم
تحديدها
لتوزيع هذه المساعدات بشكل مباشر بالدرجه
الاولى مركز الملك سلمان سيوزع هذه
المساعدات على المناطق
المتضرره وتحديدا التي يتواجد بها
النازحين اكثر نظرا لان الاوضاع الامنيه
بداخل المدن الكبرى لم يتم تحديد حتى الان
مسارات امنه لدخول مثلا على سبيل المثال
الخرطوم التي يتواجد بها هناك احتياجات
كبرى تتواجد بها على على سبيل المثال في
الطبي والقطاع ايضا الغذائي وغيرها من
احتياجات الاخرى في الخرطوم ولكن هذه
المساعدات تذهب مباشره الى النازحين الذين
يبلغ عددهم ما يقارب 300 الى 400 الف ومئه
زايدون باستمرار لذلك نشاهد ان مركز الملك
سلمان عبر هذا الجسر لغاتي ارسله مندوبي
على الارض ليقوموا بعمليه الدراسه
المتواصله لعمليه الاحتياجات وفيما اذا
كان هنالك احتياجات اخرى سيتم ارسالها عبر
الطائرات المتواصله يوميا في مطار الملك
خالد الدولي حيث وصلت الان بعدد طائرات
الى خمسه طائرات ارسلت 50 طن من المساعدان
مساعدات هذه الطائره الخامسه التي تستعد
للاقلاع مباشره والذهاب الى مطر بورتسودان
بالاضافه الى الطائرات الاخرى التي يتم
الاستعداد لارسالها خلال الايام القادمه
بالاضافه لذلك تتواصل عمليه التبرع
المباشر عبر المنصه التي تم استحداثها من
قبل منصه من قبل مركز الملك سلمان و
ايقونه مساعده الشعب السوداني عبر التبرع
المباشر التي وصلت عدد عمليات التبرع فيها
الى اكثر من 17 الف عمليه تبرع من 17 الف
شخص او وصلت عدد الاموال التي تم التبرع
فيها ثلاثه مليون ونصف المليون ريال في
خلال هذا اليوم بالاضافه الى المبلغ الذي
تم تخصيصه نايف في بدايه انطلاق هذه هذا
الجسر وتحديدا نتحدث عن 100 مليون دولار
تم تخسيسها من قبل مركز الملك سلمان
بالاضافه الى فتح المجال للمواطنين
والمقيمين في السعوديه للمساهمه في هذه
العمليه الاغاثيه العاجله لمساعده الشعب
السوداني والنازحين في مختلف مناطق
السودان وبالاضافه وبالاضافه الى خارج
السودان اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الرياض مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات